the fallen leaves tell a story and so
does Eldon ring it is something that
goes far beyond the yellow-bellied slug
we find at the end of the game it is a
story of hardships struggle and a lot of
debt and we find it told throughout our
journey in the game at first things seem
Bleak with round-the-clock you died
screens and the shattered state of the
lands between the surface of the world
is teeming With Disaster aimless foes
and emaciated faces and if we head deep
below the capital we find a most severe
cynicism in the world-ending schemes of
the frenzied flame and The psychosis of
its followers chaos
but in reality this pretense of Darkness
barely shrouds the true beautiful nature
of this epic game and our journey
throughout it as we see in characters
like Melina and Ronnie and in the game's
overarching design it is a nature that
is joyous in its affirmation of life and
embracement of struggle in this video I
want to look at the story and philosophy
that Elden ring presents along with some
of the influences that inspired its
conception of struggle and tragic Beauty
I want to dive into the real message of
our Grace guided journey and the radical
appreciation of life that it
unflinchingly delivers even after death
number 89 to a royal Revenant or an
ulcerated tree spirit
[Music]
the first step to understand Eldon
Ring's joyous outlook on suffering is to
look at one of the game's most prominent
influences the Dark Fantasy manga
berserk berserk is a long-running manga
that deals with immense struggle and
hardship and it has long been an
influential work for from software and
director hitetake Miyazaki especially in
this aspect of seeing Beauty despite
pain in an interview with rolling stone
Miyazaki said that if you were to look
at his bookshelf first you'd spot the
manga Shelf with Devilman and berserk
lining the top elements of reference to
the series can be found in many of
frimsoft's games but there is an
especially large number in Elden ring to
illustrate just a few we have the
following First Blight a blatant
reference and direct homage to the main
character of Berserk guts these two
share a nearly identical sword a canine
theme in their flesh melding armor and
an iconic crouching pose not to mention
their shared companionship with short
Mages the sword wielded by blive the
Royal Greatsword is basically a
derivative of the normal grade sword a
Mainstay in front of games and another
reference to guts and his sword the
Dragon Slayer the item description of
the great sword houses quite a number of
allusions to the manga's description of
the Dragon Slayer and of guts things
like a coarse heap of iron a defeater of
inhuman foes fun stuff and because two
sword references Aren't Enough there is
a third one in the sword monuments that
pop up all over the lands between these
bear and uncanny resemblance to the hill
of Swords a scene in berserk with their
only Chief difference being the addition
in Elden ring of the massive sword in
the Middle with the massive sword these
do look like a real-life Monument that's
in Norway the spurred ethio I don't know
if I pronounced that right but the large
sword also looks like the dragon slayer
considering that berserk's Creator
kintaro Mira passed away the year before
Elden ring came out the design of the
sword monuments makes sense to be seen
as a kind of tribute to the mangaka who
influenced the game series so much
further influences include the crystal
tiers which look identical to a tear
crystallization from berserk and there
are also design similarities between the
earth tree and berserk's World spiral
tree now the idea of such a world tree
does go far beyond berserk to many world
cultures from Norse cosmology to other
Indo-European religions but the
similarities in presentation do seem to
indicate a connection especially when
there are already so many other ties
between the two works for another design
reference we can see similarities
between melania's Wang telm and the
helmet of berserk's Lady farnese the
similarity is a relatively minor note
but the character who wears the helmet
in berserk Barneys is quite the Trove of
reference through quite a few
connections we can see that she is
deeply intertwined with our own roderica
of the lands between they are both Noble
ladies who end up needing to go down
paths very different than originally
intended they both learn magic and
develop a connection to spirits and even
more on the nose Rodrigo was actually
listed as lost Royal farnese in Elden
Rings 1.00 credits and lastly the
masculine version of roderica's name is
Roderick which just so happens to be the
name of farnes's fiancee in berserk this
list isn't exhaustive but it should give
a good idea as to the degree which from
soft and Allen ring are influenced by
berserk the connection between the works
is clear as a falconian day so it should
make sense why I want to look at berserk
in explaining the mindset and philosophy
of Elden ring this connection much like
the works themselves is deeper than just
visual designs and character names it
runs down to the very foundations and
World Views of these two works
berserk is a story about Humanity in
following its protagonist guts it
explores unimaginable levels of pain
suffering and depravity guts is
repeatedly driven to desperation and
required to push past his Breaking Point
physically as well as mentally and
emotionally the series is essentially a
charting of guts's never-ending struggle
against the horrors and monsters of the
world in addition to the overbearing
weight of Fate Destiny and determinism
it's a lot fittingly as gut struggles
against these tribulations he receives
the title of the struggler from the
skull night his BFF and local portent of
Doom the tragic nature of Berserk and
the struggling of its hero guts may seem
unceasingly dark and pessimistic any
reader of the series will agree that its
onslaught of blood guts death suffering
and turmoil often feels dreadfully heavy
and never-ending which is also something
to some degree that fans of Dark Souls
and Elden ring experience a Relentless
aesthetic of darkness and difficulty but
to conclude that this is all there is to
either of these these works is to miss
the forest for the trees the tragedy of
Berserk is not designed to get us to
give up on life to view it as some kind
of insurmountable Darkness rather its
goal is the inverse to insulin us the
beauty of life and of the struggle to
overcome despite that existing Darkness
there is a really wonderful examination
of this message and of Berserk as a
tragedy and fellow YouTuber and
philosopher Jonas chica's video berserk
as an itching tragedy in the video Jonas
explores how the suffering and tragedy
of Berserk Maps well onto the philosophy
of Frederick Nietzsche and specifically
his view of tragic art is something life
fulfilling and truly joyful it is
important to highlight just how direct
of an influence nietza is on berserk in
one chapter school night delivers a
warning to guts as he is about to start
his journey of fighting inhuman monsters
and demons skull Knight says mind this
yours is a black path through the night
when you confront those who lurk in
darkness you also envelop yourself in it
which is about as explicit of a
reference as one can get to niche's
Infamous Africa tourism he who fights
with monsters should be careful lest he
thereby become a monster and if thou
gaze long into an abyss the abyss will
also gaze into thee and even more the
warning not to become a monster is
another central theme of guts's story
so with the explicit references shown
now we can delve and do how berserk
fulfills many of the aspects of
traditional tragedies the manga first
opens somewhere in the middle of the
story so we see the state of guts only
after some tragic events have occurred
the other earlier chapters of the manga
are set before this fall but because of
this opening we know that this happier
period cannot last this setup pairs with
the Prophecies of Calamity and death
that occur in Universe to our characters
they are told their fate and there is
nothing they can do to stop it despite
whatever they may try this mirrors
traditional Greek tragedy like in
Oedipus Rex and Shakespearean tragedy
like in Macbeth where Prophecies of Doom
are foretold the elements of Prophecy
and fate are Central to berserk which it
refers to as causality or the laws of
causality that which All Things Must
abide by the natural flow of things that
no individual has any hope to resist
guts is always found working in a way
against this causality steadfastly
trying to live life according to his own
terms but Zerg does not present a naive
view of Free Will which would be
something like saying guts can overcome
causality and Fate by sheer will or
through simply trying hard enough to
choose freely that'd be a little bit too
shown but at the same time it doesn't
resign itself to a pessimistic fatalism
that discounts any personal action or
choice in the tragic tradition guts
makes his own choices but those choices
do not unilaterally free him from the
determined flow of things as the order
of the story shows the viewer or reader
guts had no way out of becoming the
tragic character we find him as in the
manga's opening without a hand an eye or
a stable Safe Life as Jonas says we know
from the very beginning that whatever
happens in between a tragedy will occur
transforming guts from this and to this
and the curse that eventually marks guts
as a sacrificial victim serves as a
symbol of the cruelty of Fate just as
much as a symbol of his struggle against
that faith yet within this tragedy and
this determined path of torturous faith
8. life is not rejected the suffering
and struggling of guts like that of
other tragic Heroes is not a
confirmation that the Terrors of Life
are enough to nullify its value instead
it is a vital aspect of the ability to
Embrace Life in its totality and to say
yes despite the darker side as Nietzsche
writes saying yes to life even in its
most strange and intractable problems
the will to life celebrating its own
inexhaustibility by sacrificing its
highest types that is what I found as
the bridge to the psychology of the
tragic poet not in order to be released
from Terror and pity but instead Beyond
Terror and pity in order to be oneself
the Eternal Joy of becoming that joy
that also includes in itself the joy of
Destruction the near Eternal state of
guts's struggle mirrors that which
Nietzsche finds most essential to the
human endeavor becoming a never-ending
process of the will to light Nietzsche
saw humans as constantly changing
without a universal Foundation to ground
our differing perspectives truths and
moralities because of this he sees
Humanity as an essentially transitory
process where the act of growing and
becoming something greater and higher is
a vital aspect of a healthy life
and this secret life itself spoke to me
behold it said I am that which must
always overcome itself
butts is one of the ideal examples of
Nietzsche's conception of becoming and
self-overcoming he is always in a state
of struggling needing to grow to
overcome his previous self that he may
survive and hold on to life his journey
even begins with a Resolute piece of
advice from Skull night struggle contend
endure that alone is the sword of the
one who confronts death who once again
quote Jonas because he does a great job
in explaining guts and his character is
precisely a call to never give in to
resignation but instead struggle beyond
all limits even when it seems
overwhelmingly futile even when the gods
are our opponents even if we're told
that the very laws of causality are
working against us guts undeniably is a
tragic hero of the nietzsian variety The
Struggle of guts is a representation of
what it takes to Live While the
afflictions of real life may not be as
immediately grotesque as the monsters of
Berserk they require The Same Spirit of
struggle and self-overcoming to be met
and at the same same time they in the
overcoming they demand illustrate the
beauty of that life Tanisha berserk like
every true tragedy shows us that at the
bottom of everything life is
indestructibly powerful and joyful in
the whirling Chasm of its suffering and
anguish we see at the same time the
entirety of life and the beauty of that
human struggle the struggle becomes art
and a consoling Force to the one who
finds themselves perplexed by the
suffering of existence in this state the
experiencer of the tragedy whether that
tragedy be a story or our real lives
finds that art saves them and through
ART life saves them and to conclude the
section with a final word from Jonas
which is only fair because of the great
debt this analysis owes to him
and Nietzsche's hope is that we can
value Life as a work of art as well to
see life as something that does not need
a happy ending to justify it because
it's Beauty
eternally justifies itself
that is what tragedy teaches us what
kintaramura created was in my view a
tragic celebration of life and in
celebrating his life we celebrate also
Life as a whole
[Music]
foreign
with knowledge in Hand of the tragic
beauty of Berserk and a taste of the
philosophy of Nietzsche we can return to
our Central Focus Elden ring to see how
it breathes the same tragic Beauty to
life both in its story and in its gift
of struggle to the player like its
predecessors Elden ring defends the
beauty of struggle and of Life game
director hiditake Miyazaki confirmed
that from software's infamously tough
approach is a vital part of their design
saying in a New Yorker interview in our
game specifically hardship is what gives
meaning to the experience so it's not
something we're willing to abandon at
the moment it's our identity this
identity is not one of oppressive
hardship for the sake of itself or some
otherwise masochistic tendency despite
what it might seem but rather out of a
desire to have as many players as
possible to experience the joy that
comes from overcoming hardship in
miyazaki's words we can see a theme of
similarity to the struggle of guts and
the tragic Beauty we already discussed
hardship offers an Avenue to experience
Joy through its overcoming and Miyazaki
Ventures that this aspect of tragic
appreciation is something that can be
especially tailored to the medium of
games saying death and rebirth trying
and overcoming we want that cycle to be
enjoyable in life death is a horrible
thing in play it can be something else
like the previous games on from soft's
mantle Elden ring makes the play version
of death a focal point of its experience
and it does this by presenting two
viewings of struggling and death one in
the narrative and one in the gameplay
while the player obviously meets with
the difficult gameplay Miyazaki intended
the player character is set up to face
hardship too Eldon Ring's Narrative of
struggling is found in our player
character's role as a tarnished in the
lands between and with many of the
characters we meet on our journey we
struggle against Monsters demigods and
gods in like manner to guts and his
cadra of similarly Supernatural foes we
Face unending defeat and death but
coming back to life at sights of Grace
and Stakes of America we continue to
fight undeterred by the hardship we
abide by school night's advice to
struggle and endure Pacers of death that
we are a narrative focus on perseverance
is commonplace for from Saul while it
was showcased most aptly in Dark Souls
with the narrative mechanic of Halloween
feel free to check out my video on the
subject it still maintains in strong
fashion in Eldon ring and in the
underdog status of our tarnished Once
spurned By Grace this also plays into
the justification of the tragic like we
saw in Nietzsche and berserk by us
playing as tarnished the game defends
and justifies struggle by setting up our
journey to be dependent on it our
character cannot succeed at the game's
stated goals whether that be overcoming
demigods reaching the Earth tree or
mending the Elden ring without
struggling and self-overcoming the
self-overcoming even happens literally
too through the in-game leveling
mechanic and we have thereby found out
that level 1 runs are confirmed not
canon each level we add is our character
tangibly becoming stronger than they
were before the game also features
numerous other characters and story
elements which serve a similar narrative
role of signaling to the player that the
struggle is worth it I'll leave the
details of each until a later section
but just to highlight a few of the major
examples there is Melina our content
companion who emphatically rejects the
frenzy flame and its denial of light
whereas it would delve the world into
chaos to Cease the suffering of
individuated Life Melania would protect
and further life and the beauty within
it this corresponds to the views of
Nietzsche and seeing art and Beauty as a
Saving Grace a metaphysical comfort from
the reality of suffering there is also
Ronnie who features the longest and most
substantial quest in the game opening up
whole new areas of exploration along
with an iconic boss fight in her Quest
and ending we see that she seeks
self-determination and the chance to
have individual choice in life despite
its cost of solitude and darkness this
corresponds to Nietzsche's emphasis on
absolute freedom of self and as the
price of this Freedom how one must be
accustomed to living on mountaintops and
for a final example there are the
various NPCs like gold mask via and the
dung eater who craft their own endings
trying in spite of the machinations of
gods and a corrupted world to make
change in that world struggling to make
it a better place while better is in air
quotes for the dung either
Elden ring never stops embracing its
narrative struggle and in doing so it
offers the beauty of the world of lands
between and our experience playing
through it a quote from Nietzsche that
Jonas uses to refer to berserk applies
just as well here to Elven ring that its
stunning visuals and grandiose World
reveal a fantastic excess of light this
excess contrasts with any shrinking away
from life or embracement of pessimism or
the flame of frenzy through the darkness
the light and Beauty shine and as Maria
from Euro Thug 4000 puts it beautifully
in her video on Elden ring is that
flowers bloom even on battlefields
and Maria also says of Elden ring that
to me this is from soft's game that's
most full of life in comparison to the
souls games which was just too close to
niche's phrase excess of life for me to
not include it right here
while our own tarnished character
doesn't necessarily have a tragic
prophecy they do have to face a dark
World tragic figures and unending
struggle just like guts and other tragic
Heroes and depending on our choice of
ending we can have a tragic conclusion
too but as we saw with miyazaki's
comments the experience of this world is
also tragic for us the player our player
character doesn't struggle alone after
all from a gameplay perspective Elden
ring is hard as is characteristic for
from software Elden ring is a difficult
game now I'm sure there are plenty of
cheeky creators article writers and
Reddit commenters that are jumping up
and down to say that Elden ring isn't
hard it's actually just and I I don't
care I don't you die a lot during a
playthrough you encounter lots of
failure Ergo the game's hard it is
difficult saying anything else is
penantry especially when Miyazaki
himself says that hardship is our
identity with this difficulty we as
players find ourselves struggling we
must go through the same acceptance of
struggle and self-overcoming as guts
though we do have somewhat lower Stakes
playing a video game rather than
fighting demons which are hunting us to
the death now in game we Face the
repeated death that the game demands of
us dying to its virtual monsters and
demigods in our struggle to reach the
game's end those of us who do reach that
end only do so by becoming better at the
game learning the enemies attacks to
some degree at least and overcoming the
older versions of ourselves who were
unable to Vanquish the tree Sentinel at
the start of the game this struggle of
gameplay is one more aspect of Elton
ring delivering to the player the
message of worthwhile tragedy like we
have seen in nieta and berserk and this
aspect is also highlighted well by a
contemporary professor and philosopher
of games CT Nguyen who I only now
realize is the only living thinker that
I am sourcing ideas from in this video
in his book games agencies art Nguyen
looks at our reasons for playing games
especially difficult ones where he
discusses gameplay engaged in for the
sake of the aesthetic quality of the
struggle to Nguyen one of the main
reasons we take up games is that we get
a positive experience from our gameplay
from the delicately crafted struggle
found in Elven ring players are doing
something difficult for the experience
of Harmony between their utmost
capacities and the Practical World our
abilities match up with the challenges
of the game and this harmony gives us a
pleasurable experience the challenge
engages Us in real life there is often
no such Harmony our abilities fall short
of the tasks or the tasks are horribly
dull but in games unlike in life The
Experience can be designed in such a way
as to bring the challenge in line with
our capacity as a person or to try to
reclaim that modern day slur as a gamer
this affords us a pristine opportunity
for overcoming and a way to get familiar
with the process of overcoming in a kind
of controlled environment which has been
sculpted by the game designer it is the
same as in the case of Literature Like
berserk where all the challenges and
struggles were sculpted by the story's
author to be the perfect fit for the
story's hero the story of guts is of a
character struggling through precisely
what kintaro Mira had designed for him
that he may overcome and that we as an
audience May appreciate this overcoming
and the life that allows it however
unlike literature or any other medium
the occurrence of this process in games
and video games brings with it a unique
experience the reader of Berserk or The
Watcher of a movie must to some degree
passively absorb the work they are
experiencing there isn't anything to do
but follow along with the words or
pictures in contrast a game is only
possible with the activity of the player
Elden ring can't play itself the player
has to give some input or else they'll
stand at the first step all day getting
called maidenless by are you are made in
this in this active gameplay comes a
unique opportunity for artistic
appreciation Elden ring presents not
only tragic Beauty and affirmation of
life but it presents these as something
for us to experience as players the
gameplay that Nguyen discussed that we
engage in for the sake of struggle is
part of his definition of something
called aesthetic striving play this is a
specific kind of gameplay that occurs
when a player takes up a game or
challenge not necessarily for the
purpose of winning but more importantly
for the experience of the play for
experiential qualities of the struggle
according to Nguyen Nguyen introduces
this definition through a discussion
about him and his spouse playing a board
game High Frontier he talks about how
their skills are evenly matched and that
this makes for wonderfully thrilling and
mesmerizing matches Newman says that
despite the thrilling High effort
gameplay he is obviously not playing
with a final purpose of winning yes of
course while he is playing he is trying
to win but he does not pursue this end
at the exclusion of all else after all
as he notes he could read strategy
guides or get training from a more
experienced player this would jump him
ahead in skill and lead to him winning
more often but he doesn't do this when
holds back at the cost of a higher
chance of Victory because winning isn't
his most valuable goal plain is
specifically playing with a high degree
of struggle and difficulty that's where
the fun is
the aesthetic striving play that nguin
describes here is Possible only if we
can as he argues pick on two different
agencies an agency here being an ability
to act as an agent to make choices to
decide things and to reflect on and
consider those decisions Nguyen says
this gameplay where you're not actually
trying to win but you're trying to win
in a moment involves two layers of
agency one outer layer agency is where
we value the play and appreciate the
aesthetic experience of struggle that
occurs while we play it's sort of a more
passive Observer and it's what decides
not to read strategy guides in wins case
another inner layer agency is where we
are trying to actually win while playing
the game it's the active layer that is
involved in the real-time plane and
trying to win this dual agency according
to Nguyen allows us to aesthetically
appreciate our own experience of
gameplay the outer layer can reflect and
Marvel at what the inner layer is doing
this is what allows many Elden ring
veterans who desperately want to beat
the game to handicap themselves with
self-imposed rules like no summons magic
only melee strength builds basically the
from soft equivalent to 1v1v Fox Final
Destination no items they are doing what
Nguyen did with high Frontier while
playing with summons would let them win
faster it would also take away what they
really want the mesmerizing moments with
the combat and bosses of the game they
well it's sometimes we want to
intimately learn the kids of the bosses
even if it takes dozens of deaths we
want the struggle of the gameplay
whereas Melania with mimic tier can be a
cakewalk Melania solo can be a clinic in
suffering and this suffering is part of
what makes the experience a fun one and
an artistic one
video games like Elden ring can offer
tragic struggle as art that can not only
be appreciated but actively Taken part
in to appreciate the suffering and
overcoming required for Life mitcha
thought we had to see it aesthetically
as art we should really look upon
ourselves as beautiful pictures and
artistic projections of the true creator
and in that significance as works of art
we have our highest value for only as an
aesthetic phenomena our existence and
the world eternally Justified
in games we can actively take on this
role as artistic projections as we meld
with the game itself through gameplay in
our appreciation of our own struggle as
art we find justification first for the
struggle of the game then for the
struggle of life and finally for Life as
a whole
foreign
of tragic Beauty and from soft games
I've tried to show that it isn't just
gameplay or story Elden ring like the
souls franchise before it delivers a
struggle and narrative as well as
gameplay but even that recognition
leaves something out it is not just that
these two aspects of the game hit the
same theme it's something that goes even
further Beyond this in mirroring and
emphasizing each other the gameplay and
the narrative combine to create the Ludo
narrative a term occasionally abused in
the world of game analysis but one that
is indispensable if we want to talk
about games that utilize their gameplay
to help tell their story The Ludo
narrative is something I talked about in
my dark souls and Halloween videos and
it is even more relevant to that game
but it's still an important part of the
story of Elden ring more than the sum of
their parts gameplay and narrative
coinciding can create a more intense
full-fledged experience of our
particular game's message we're Alden
ring this message is the importance and
value of struggling persevering through
hardship to a overcome it's not just
that the gameplay is hard and the story
shows people or our character enduring
it's that the gameplay reaffirms The
Narrative message by incorporating that
message into itself the gameplay
delivers the message The Story presents
and because it is gameplay this means
that we as players actively experience
the message we receive we play a part in
creating the Luna narrative idea and
message of the game this also
re-emphasizes nuin's framework of
aesthetic striving play again we get a
two-prong fork first we get to
appreciate the aesthetic experience of
our gameplay the struggle which is found
up to and in the harmony of our skills
and the game's challenges we get to
Marvel at that fronts off balance of
combat and our part in it but now we
gain a second aspect of appreciation we
appreciate the aesthetic experience of
the game's creation of Ludo narrative
how our gameplay reifies the game's
narrative message of struggle we help
create the ludo-narrative experience and
at the same time we appreciate that EXP
variance and that creation this double
level of creation also delivers strongly
on our nichean analysis we saw before
that by understanding Life As Art in the
world and in struggling to be justified
but we cannot forget that art is
something which must be created so only
through the creation of that life art
through the justification of Life take
place in Nietzsche's words creation that
is the great Redemption from suffering
and life's growing light in this
Treasure of creation is where Nietzsche
finds that the entire world of Torment
is necessary so that through it the
individual is pushed to create the
Redemptive vision and then absorbed in
contemplation of that Vision sits
quietly in his robot tossing around in
the middle of the ocean one of the most
powerful ways that games like no other
medium can provide this Arc is by
utilizing the Ludo narrative the blend
of game and story in doing so games like
Elden ring can call us as players into
the creation of Art and at the same time
they go further they let us appreciate
that art that let us take part in the
contemplation on the rowboat
now before we reach the finale of the
video I wanted to expand a bit on the
really strong nietzsian Vibes of some of
the characters and story elements in
Elden ring this isn't technically
necessary to deliver the main point of
the video so you can skip to the final
section if you're pressed for time but I
think it does a good job of fleshing out
the nichean themes like the value of
struggle and of life and how prevalent
they are throughout the game the first
and most prominent of these examples can
be found in Melina and her opposition to
the frenzy plane as I mentioned at the
start of the video the deepest cynicism
and rejection of life that can be found
in Eldon ring is in the frenzy flame and
its accolades the three fingers shibiri
and hayata I covered this in my previous
video on the forensic flame but it's
worth repeating here as it's really
relevant to the discussion the frenzy
flame wishes to end life in the lanes
between it wants to melt everything away
with a yellow chaos flame hayata
Explains It All what was it there is
came from the one great thinking
fractures
and births
and souls for the greater will made a
mistake torment
spare
Affliction every sin Every curse
everyone born of the mistake and so
what was borrowed
must be returned melted all away with
the yellow chaos flame until all is one
again
the philosophy of the frenzy flame is
that of pessimism a view that life's
Pleasures are not worth its suffering so
it would rather end Life as We Know It
melting away our individual experiences
to meld us all together as one where we
will no longer suffer the pain of having
an individual realized Consciousness but
Elden ring does not present this as
simply another option among many when we
are one step away from committing to the
path of the chaos flame we may receive
the wisdom of Grace Melania our constant
companion throughout the game offers a
rebuttal if you intend to claim the
frenzied flame I ask that you cease it
is not to be meddled with it is chaos
devouring life and thought unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue There is Beauty in that
is there not
if you would become Lord
do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
Melina offers this pleading from a
thematically privileged position she is
someone who like torrent has been on our
side from the very beginning the game
never gives us any reason to doubt her
or view her as a malicious actor in this
way the game itself Advocates against
the path of the frenzy Flame by having
its rebuttal be delivered by one of the
game's only seemingly chill and decent
people and this message is furthered by
its syncing up with the other themes and
influences of the game like devaluing of
Life despite its Associated struggle we
can see a similar back and forth to the
frenzied flame and Melina in the works
of philosopher Arthur schopenhauer and
yup you guessed it Freddy in Egypt
schopenhauer was actually Nietzsche's
main philosophical mentor and he was
also a full-fledged pessimist and denier
of life he had much to say on how life
is a disappointment and we can get a
flavor of his thoughts in the following
passage if you try to imagine as nearly
as you can what an amount of misery pain
and suffering of every kind The Sun
Shines upon in its course you will admit
that it would be much better if on the
earth as little as on the moon the sun
were able to call forth the phenomena of
life and if here as there the surface
were still in a crystalline state it is
from this influence why we are able to
read from nature quotes that sound like
they could have come directly from the
frenzy plane things like we must
therefore regard the state of
individuation of life as the source and
Primal cause of all suffering as
something objectionable in itself not
too far from the language of mistake
used by hayata but recall that in this
analogy Nietzsche stands as Melina's
counterpart not a chaos sympathizer and
he is able to do so because he broke
with schopenhauer and how he thought we
should respond to the character of life
nature agreed on the prevalence of
suffering and respected schopenhauer for
his ability to call out this truth but
instead of clinging to morality and
decrying life as evil ninja chose to let
morality go so that he could accept
light Embrace its beauty and say yes to
it and it is in tragedy that Nietzsche
says we find a metaphysical Comfort
which shows us that in spite of the
Perpetual change of phenomena life at
bottom is indestructibly powerful and
joyful the Perpetual change of phenomena
can be read as the fractures that the
three fingers speak of and the comfort
of tragedy of art lines up nicely with
melania's pleading to Value the beauty
in the world Melina is the mouthpiece of
Nietzsche and an advocate of life she
offers a rare occasion where the game
directly communicates its message to say
yes to the struggle to say yes to life
and while they aren't quite as explicit
other characters in the game Echo this
advice we see it in strong display with
Ronnie and her ending of stars the game
nudges us toward this Ending by having
it come at the culmination of Ronnie's
Quest a quest which is the most involved
in the game opening up new sections of
the map and bringing us one of the
game's most iconic boss encounters now
this doesn't prove that this is the
Canon ending from self rarely gives such
a declaration but I do think all of this
content being associated with one Quest
shows that from Salt View's Ronnie's
Quest and ending as one of the most
important and the themes of this ending
are another example of the valuing of
life and self-overcoming I've already
explored the interpretations of this
ending in previous videos both in the
voiced English and in the original
Japanese as there are some translation
issues with the English despite the
issues I came to a similar conclusion in
both analyzes that the seeming dark
portent of the ending was not as
Sinister as it seemed that Ronnie's
ending was actually one of Hope and
self-determination it is a recognition
that life comes with problems in
Ronnie's case the order and the
influence of Gods but that we can still
value life all the same and we should
strive to overcome these issues though
it may take us on a path of fear doubt
and loneliness Into Darkness despite a
dark exterior this ending is resolutely
one of Hope and of striving for the
better in this way it mirrors Nietzsche
and his philosophy which is often
maligned as that of an edgy atheist but
does truly have dark overtones in its
acceptance of the gravity of suffering
this is akin to Ronnie's ending which is
seemingly dark but in reality its core
is one of Hope and a positive view of
Life the self-determination of Ronnie
also mirrors the self-determination that
nature prescribed for Humanity in the
wake of the death of God as he saw it
whereas Ronnie can only push away the
influence of the outer Gods nietzsa saw
our society is having to Grapple with
the end of the concept of God the
upsurging lack of faith in society
eroding him entirely and exposing him as
a concept created by Humanity nietzsa
saw this moment as a freeing one just as
Rani and we as her tarnished consort
must chart a path in the cold night sky
Nicha saw this moment like the charting
of a course on a now open sea of
morality and human valuing finally The
Horizon seems clear again even if not
bright finally our ships May set out
again set out to face any danger every
daring of the lover of knowledge is
allowed again the sea our sea lies open
again maybe there has never been such an
open seat Tanisha this freeing moment
was a new dawn and while Ronnie's ending
may be one of the night it cannot always
be night the Dawn and the day come it is
up to us only whether we are ready for
them and through Ronnie's journey I see
the message of Elden ring as one which
implores us to be ready to live joyously
in the along
I'll also take just a moment to comment
on the other ending variants of the game
the ones we get from FIA gold mask and
the dung eater in each of these we see
lowly tarnish doing their best to write
the corrupted World they find themselves
in okay maybe dung eater doesn't really
want to write the world per se but you
can't say he's not struggling this
ability to stand up to the Brokenness of
the world and decide that life is worth
trying to struggle for something better
speaks to these characters and their
ability to say yes to life in them we
see another example of the kind of Niche
and acceptance of life and struggle that
I have been tracing in the game
throughout the video
and lastly before I conclude this
section I want to make a special note of
a more minor character in the lanes
between I want to talk about the warrior
jar Iron Fist Alexander Alexander could
Charlie be the subject of his own video
as was Ronnie and to some degree Melina
but I cannot avoid speaking about him
here for he fits too well with so many
nietzschean ideals Alexander is a
yesayer like no other despite his form
being a poor and fragile fit for the
world he gains himself a warrior and
inspires others to the same ideal
Tanisha a man or a man jar in this case
must be trained for war all else is
folly as a warrior Alexander surely fits
this prescription but more importantly
he is one who strives to always grow and
overcome his past failings he absorbs
Warriors after the Rodan Festival I'll
grow even stronger he tempers himself in
the fires of Mount gelmir oh Mountain of
Fire Bake Me In Your Flames he seeks out
challenge in combat and Revels in its
glory and in the culmination of
Alexander's story we find a true moment
of tragedy and beautiful exuberance of
Life at our last meeting we find each
other in faram Azula and Alexander
marveling at our slain of the fire giant
makes a request of us a request to do
battle I've been longing to fight a
warrior as accomplished as you to see a
friend as a rival and to respect their
strength is how Nietzsche thought that
we should view friendship he says in
one's friend one should have One's best
enemy in honoring this final request of
Alexander we present him with his best
enemy and in Warrior respect and shared
understanding he may be ours as well the
fight commences and it is hard fought
at its end Alexander in a brilliant
acceptance of Life says this all vessels
are destined to one day break
but the great Alexander lived as a
warrior to his last
[Music]
Iron Fist Alexander lip despite his
circumstances in the crumbling world
around him he lived as one of The
Shining examples of positivity and
exuberant Vitality in the lanes between
he died in laughter a most nichean way I
pronounced laughter holy you hire men
learn to laugh Alexander Shirley learned
and in him we can see the whole message
of Eldon rank to say yes to life to
laugh
[Music]
through its darkness and tragic elements
Eldon Reign doesn't shy away from the
reality of our world it recognizes the
suffering and struggling that demarcate
our existence from that of inert matter
but at the same time it does not fall to
cynicism or pessimism through this
recognition like Nietzsche the tragic
poets and berserk it instead Embraces
light struggle and all it accepts that
this is our lot in existence and
exclaims the beauty of our tragedy Eldon
ring reaches some of the highest Heights
in the world of video games and Tanisha
it is only fitting that whoever climbs
the highest mountain laughs at all
tragic plays and tragic realities this
laughter is an affirmative response to
the question of life to all that comes
with the tragic World it says yes it
accepts all the struggling suffering and
perseverance that allow us to see and
experience that tragic existence Elden
ring reflects the tragic beauty of our
world through its gameplay narrative and
especially its combination of these
elements it espouses a philosophy of
struggle that finds understanding in the
works of project ninja kintaro Mira and
CT Newman this struggle is both a pain
and a ball a curse and a blessing simply
it is life and concerning this life of
curse each must decide for themselves
whether it is worth the cost it demands
but in the context of Elden ring it's
clear to me that the admission price is
peanuts compared to the exuberant beauty
that the game delivers
I want to say a big thank you to
everyone who watched this video
especially to the end while I've
explored these ideas a little bit in
other videos I haven't dedicated a video
to this style other than my frenzy flame
one and this is an even further push in
a New Direction especially with the game
analysis I hope it was enjoyable as I
would really like to do more of this
kind of content for Elden ring and other
games I think this kind of Niche is one
I really have the skill set to do well
in with that I'd like to especially
thank my patrons for supporting the
channel and if you want to join in that
support there will be links to do so on
the screen and in the description
everyone thanks again for watching I'll
see you in the next video and in the
meantime I hope this is a support the
argument even just a little bit the
right answer is to say yes to life
bye